horas antes de recibir ocho disparos
durante una manifestación en la ciudad
de pereira lucas biglia un joven
universitario mostraba su rechazo a la
violencia policial mientras marchaba
pacíficamente más tarde sevilla fue
atacado desde un vehículo por
desconocidos junto a otras dos personas
ahora el joven permanece en estado
crítico y su pronóstico es reservado y
se ha convertido en un símbolo de las
protestas en colombia desde la alcaldía
de pereira se ofrecen 50 millones de
pesos cerca de 13 mil 100 dólares por
los responsables pero muchos culpan al
alcalde que instó a las fuerzas privadas
a hacer un frente común contra los
manifestantes vamos a convocar a todos
los gremios de la ciudad ya los miembros
de la seguridad privada para hacer un
frente común junto a la policía y el
ejército para recuperar el orden en la
seguridad ciudad otros manifestantes
como nicolás guerrero caleño de 22 años
que murió por un disparo en la cabeza la
noche del 2 de mayo han sido víctimas de
la violencia policial también jefferson
alexis marín murió
un impacto de bala en la cabeza en
medellín junto a otros 352 ciudadanos
que han resultado heridos según fuentes
oficiales la violencia policial es algo
inaceptable totalmente inaceptable desde
el inicio de las protestas el 28 de
abril la defensoría del pueblo ha
contabilizado 24 muertos aunque ongs
como temblores contabilizan 37
fallecidos y más de 1.700 agresiones
policiales para frenar las protestas el
gobierno de iván duque aseguró que está
dispuesto al diálogo estas protestas
están en la línea de las que vivió el
país entre 2019 y 2020 por mejoras
sociales y en contra de la violencia
policial y que dejaron 12 fallecidos